actually give us a bit more detail as to
what he was doing in iraq in the first
place and how he came to come across
these items
yep he was on a trip on a geology
archangel trip
in iraq um after covert i mean he hadn't
he hadn't gone on holiday for more than
two years and he was looking forward to
this to this trip um
he's never been to iraq and it's a a
guided tour
um and uh
for two weeks
for two weeks
and um
um after
oh he would he would text us every day
and um would we check on him and
everything was fine until
um the day he was he was leaving um that
baghdad airport
um
he said there was a hold up
and we that that was it you know there
was a hold up and and with customs and
he didn't he didn't
really explain what
what else um so we thought okay maybe um
just a bit of a delay um but um he
couldn't well he didn't turn up in in kl
and
um
after her
sorry
um after yeah sorry about that oh that's
okay i appreciate it's difficult sam
perhaps you could take over i'll speak
to um to layla again in a moment it's
okay no no
yes so uh so so jim one of one of the
sites that they visited on the tour was
a a site called eradu aeradu
which is a an ancient site in iraq it's
it's a desert sort of strewn with
big chunks of masonry and you know sort
of small ruined walls and things
mostly desert though
and
on the floor surrounding the site and
all over the desert are these tiny
pieces of pottery and broken stone um
which
jim uh asked if he could take homes as a
souvenir um so there's no sign instead
of guards there's no fencing of any kind
of sights no warnings that this is not
only illegal but carries a death
sentence
um and jim was accompanied by a tour
guide with over 40 years experienced by
a representative from the ministry of
tourism in iraq and by a former police
officer acting security and
none of them registered any protest
about about you know his request so so
he picked up a few pieces and put them
in his bag to take home as a souvenir
mostly sort of the size of your
fingernail you've got some pictures
there
and he was was was arrested at the
airport his tour guide was uh was taken
ill with a stroke at the airport um
another british citizen who
unfortunately passed away in iraq a few
days followed
and um and jim was jim was arrested for
attempting to smuggle historical
artifacts out of the country and
we've been managing the situation and
trying to trying to help him
get home safe ever since
sam from what you told us
i mean your father-in-law is a
retired um
geologist he did ask he could take those
items
he was
you say given misinformation he was
unaware of iraqi law
and from what we can gather another man
was on trial as well he was acquitted
because he showed no criminal
intent
can you talk me through that how it was
that your father wasn't able your
father-in-law wasn't able to show that
he meant no criminal intent given what
you've told us
yes so i the the difference the
difference between the two and and and
the reason that the germans was actually
around around who actually physically
picked up the pieces off the ground so
so jim picked up the pieces off the
ground and later gave
to to the german man we understand that
souvenirs for himself
um that's where the distinction lies
between the two but the judge the judge
himself admitted that jim also had no no
criminal intent and indeed was not aware
of the law that he was breaking when
when you know they were in the desert
um and that's why this this verdict is
so hard for us to swallow really it's it
it it's almost in direct contradiction
of of comments made by the judge himself
so
we are we are hopeful about about the
appeal and that the verdict will be
we'll be questioned at the appeals court
but uh obviously just at the moment just
kind of shell-shocked and devastated
trying to get any help we can to to
support and bolster the appeal yeah
we'll talk about what you're doing in
just a moment but leila have you been
able to speak to your dad
as soon as we heard um
the verdict i i tried calling him
and he we were lucky enough to get to
speak to him and uh he was just shocked
because
we were feeling positive uh leading up
to
trial yesterday
and
uh he was yeah he was he was calm
he was just shocked and i was i mean i
hadn't spoken to him for
93 days and it was
it was nice to hear his voice
and i was obviously getting a bit
emotional but he
he stayed strong and
yes i mean his his focus was on was on
the practical things so making sure that
that there's enough
money available for for later's mom to
buy food and pay bills you know whilst
he's whilst he's away um
making sure that we've sorted out you
know getting everything into the right
people's names um just just you know in
case we don't see him for for 15 years
is kind of what he's thinking
oh later i imagine that's unfathomable
for you
it's a life sentence that is age isn't
it
yes i mean we were obviously keen for
the first half of this process to
to make sure that was aware that the
death penalty was in play and obviously
we are we are grateful that jim was not
sentenced to the death penalty but
for a 66 year old man
15 years in an iraqi jail this
sentimental death penalty as far as as
far as we're concerned you know if he
does if he does get out of prison after
that period of time he'll be 81 years
old and obviously
completely changed by the experience
so sam what are your options what are
your next steps
um so we've
we've we've raised the appeal the appeal
will be will be put in place in the next
few days at which point there's a sort
of a 30-day
timeline for the appeal to be to be
reviewed and i've either favored it to
be quashed or upheld um
past that we don't know i mean uh
i've i've i've moved out to malaysia for
a few months to be
with the family obviously still working
full-time but we
we need to just look after the people
close to us at the moment as priority
number one um and and you know
work as hard as we can to to do
everything possible to get jim home safe
elena just a final word from you what
would you say to those people who may be
in a position to help your father
the thing i feel so helpless because
we've had so much support
and i mean thank you so much we've had
emails calls messages
from all over the world and it's been
really overwhelming and
i just feel so helpless because i wish i
know what to do yeah there's no playbook
for something like this when this when
this happens to you there's nobody who
phones you up tells you how to deal with
it and you know the foreign office has
provided us with sort of basic
on-the-ground consular support we
haven't provided with any political
support we've never spoken with any
minister no matter how junior about this
case and all the weeks we've been
shouting about it
um we feel like we've been left on our
own really yeah
well laila and sam um it's been good to
talk to you this afternoon raising
awareness
of your father and your father-in-law's
um plight in iraq sentenced to 15 years
in prison as she said you were going
through the appeals process now and
please keep in touch with us let us know
what happens and we will speak again um
leyla fritten and sam tasker there
speaking on behalf of jim fitton
who is in an iraqi jail as we said for
taking
artifacts out of iraq it was against
iraqi law he said he was told it was
okay we did have a statement from the
foreign office to bring you as well uh
the foreign spokesperson telling sky we
are providing consular assistance to a
british national in iraq and continue to
support his family we are in contact
with the local authorities we'll keep
you up to date on that story here on sky
news